Mary Reese you wanted to commute her
sentence you sent her back to a parole
board she's been in prison for a series
of burglaries not nothing but clearly
not a violent offender right she failed
her parole hearing based on having
borrowed I think hair gel from another
prisoner and some other things and on
the flip side of it you have an offender
who was let out and killed a police
officer yeah yeah recently
devastating devastating yeah that
person that killed the police officer
the district attorney
accuse me being responsible that's for
that I lived the reality I don't know
them it's not intellectual that's a
living sure and that puts you on your
heels
actually put me on my toes right you
want reform and you want to be I want
Public Safety I want real Public Safety
I want people to feel safe it's about
your own self-interest it's so
interesting to me it's about your own
self-interest Gavin Newsom doesn't give
about anyone's self-interest in
California after what he's done for the
last couple years